inauguration par jacques chirac ce matin
du salon de l'agriculture un événement
une attraction pour le bonheur des plus
petits qui découvrent tous les animaux
de la ferme
le monde rural en angleterre défilent
dans les rues de londres les chasseurs
et les éleveurs font cause commune pour
qu'on les laisse vivre le décès du
cardinal archevêque de lyon monseigneur
balance était un ce matin une semaine
après avoir été nommé cardinal par le
pape jean paul ii football avec
l'exploit d'un club amateur l'équipe de
bourg peronnas éliminé metz en huitièmes
de finale de la coupe de france
une victoire inattendue de 0 cinéma avec
la cérémonie des césar qui a plébiscité
le film d'alain resnais sept césars pour
on connaît la chanson a trop fait enfin
pour nous des sons et la jeunette de
demarcus ariane ascaride et sacrée
meilleure actrice de l'année
elle est l'invitée de ce journal madame
monsieur bonsoir un dimanche à la
campagne pour les parisiens qui sont
venus en nombre dès l'ouverture ce matin
du salon de l'agriculture
le vedettes du jour sont
incontestablement les animaux de la
ferme qui ont quitté leur étable pour
parader malgré le stress de la ville
l'émerveillement des enfants et un goût
de fête dans les stands
j'arrive perrin magne ribeiro c'est
l'histoire d'une grosse vache et de
petits parisiens
une histoire que les parents racontent
tous les ans début mars
car le premier jour au salon de
l'agriculture c'est le jour des familles
difficile de se passer de l'aubaine une
leçon de choses à sa porte avant c'est
vrai qu'on sait 100 km
oui voir des vaches et des poulets
lapins mais aujourd'hui non non non
c'est pas un passant de l'agriculture
puis dans les champs au loin et sinon en
général les vaches sont pas près de la
route de l'année et il y a toujours un
pour qui ce secret a confié à son animal
préféré la traite aussi a beaucoup de
succès celle des brebis par exemple le
lait de celle là sert à la fabrication
du report la naissance du jour
ces deux petits agneaux sonné à cinq
heures du matin les appeler comme en
maintenant leurs mails et numéros pour
les reconnaître numéro ses produits du
terroir la grande foule
là le salon ressemble à la soif de paris
on goûte on mange et on fait ses
emplettes en vivant à paris on a
l'habitude à vouloir faire trop vite
donc en l'espace d'une après midi ont
fait un tour de france
c'est pratique ça pèse parfois et au
moins ils espèrent avoir acheté des
produits de qualité et c'est avec un
plaisir gourmand que jacques chirac a
inauguré ce matin ce 35e le salon
international de l'agriculture le chef
de l'état cioni durant trois heures une
partie de son enfance mille mètres
carrés de cette ferme immense promenade
du pompier par des poignées de main et
des encouragements en compagnie du
ministre de l'agriculture et de la pêche
ne l'est pas c'est que jacques chirac a
promis aux paysans que la france
parleraient d'une même voix de celles
sur la prochaine réforme de la politique
agricole le pnue et nous rejoignons
maintenant en direct de la porte de
versailles pascal golomer vous vous
trouvez dans le quartier réservé au
bétail est ce que vous pourriez nous
présenter les spécimens qui se trouve à
vos côtés lavez la crise je vais vous
présenter espion qui hélas un magnifique
taureau de 1200 kg de la race aubrac est
l'un des mille trois cents animaux
présents à ce salon grandes vedettes
évidemment auprès du public
un salon qui veut avant tout parler de
qualité cette année qualité des produits
qualité de l'environnement respect des
traditions et du terroir
une opération séduction une opération
d'image pour une agriculture qui se veut
de plus en plus industrielles également
avec des choix pas toujours facile à
expliquer au public relevant ce moment
avec le débat autour des organismes
génétiquement modifiés les ogm le maïs
transgénique par exemple dans le salon
c'est une vitrine c'est aussi un grand
rendez vous pour les professionnels avec
le concours général agricole ça
représente des enjeux économiques
j'ai à côté de moi monsieur lafon
monsieur lafon bonsoir vous venez de la
région de salaire ça fait combien de
temps que vous venez au salon
d'aviculture de 20 ans 20 ans de
présence avant civile depuis vingt ans
c'était souvent des raisons quel est
l'intérêt de venir ici à paris bon
l'intérêt c'est pour promouvoir la race
salers beauchalot pourra faire connaître
pour la développer et en plus bon jeu
je vais juste me réjouis beaumont
l'elevage à moi ça fait un peu plus pour
mon usage comme butin plus c'était que
ces taureaux là vous allez présenter au
concours que ça représente une victoire
un concours et une victoire que ces
produits peuvent se vendre un peu mieux
voilà ça se vend mieux ça se vend plus
cher du che à une solution pour moi et
puis c'est surtout pour la race ou
promouvoir la race la salle et a envie
aucune race quelle est la hauteur de
n'importe quelle version vous pourriez
vous passer d'une présence ici au salon
s'il ya une seule chose si la sélection
me laisse derrière bien sûr sinon c'est
toute l'année j'ai même que quand on est
pris pour le salon alors un souci on
sera en compétition mardi prochain c'est
un grand jour pour vous et pour le
taureau le salon lui est ouvert jusqu'à
dimanche prochain pour tous les
visiteurs
donc rendez vous avec les bêtes n'y a
pas que les bêtes ya énormément de
choses à voir donc jusqu'à dimanche soir
prochain
merci parce qu'elle de la mer et merci à
votre invité l'archevêque de lyon nommé
cardinal il ya quelques jours mon
seigneur ballan est décédé tôt ce matin
des suites d'un cancer monseigneur
ballan avait reçu dimanche dernier à
rome l'anneau de cardinal lors de ce
voyage il était apparu très fatigué le
président de la république a salué les
hautes qualités morales et
intellectuelles de cet homme d'église
philippe harrouard dimanche dernier
place saint-pierre monseigneur ballan
miné par la maladie et reçoit de jean
paul ii son anneau de cardinal cérémonie
éprouvante qui succède à une autre la
veille où il se voit confier la barre et
rouge signe de sa nouvelle distinction
c'est fatigant
4 philosophe de formation fils de
vigneron jean balan né dans le
sancerrois
étant donné prêtre en 1960 et un évêque
de dijon puis archevêque de reims
il succède en 1995 à lyon au cardinal
decourtray contrairement à son
prédécesseur ce n'est pas un échec
médiatique mais un homme discret qui
gère simplement son diocèse
je regrette que lyon perde un grand
homme d'église parce que le cardinal
balle en or était certainement un grand
archevêque et malheureusement deux ans
est très court et malheureusement aussi
n'a été très très peu connue des
lyonnais le cardinal lustiger qui
célébrait ce matin la messe à chartres
évoque un évêque admirable et un prêtre
d'une très grande valeur
il savait qu'il allait mourir je savais
aussi et c'était un fils de vigneron et
quand on est fils de vigneron au travail
et à travailler jusqu'au bout
y a pas tenu compte de sa maladie il
savait que sa vie était maintenant
menacés il a fait son travail jusqu'au
bout ça c'est tout l'or raymond barre le
maire de lyon qui était à rome le
week-end dernier salue la profonde
spiritualité la finesse et la
distinction du cardinal ballan
archevêque de lyon disparu ce dimanche
le ministère de la santé vient de
communiquer les derniers chiffres
concernant le sida en france aujourd'hui
près de vingt mille personnes sont
atteintes soit une diminution des
nouveaux cas amorcée depuis 1994 malgré
cette amélioration
il faut savoir que le nombre de
personnes traitées est en augmentation
dans les banlieues ce qui pose la
question de la précarité et de
l'exclusion
stéphane guay et guy saab à vivre avec
le sida sans pouvoir se soigner
marie est séropositive elle le sait
depuis dix ans mais longtemps en
situation précaire elle était exclue du
système de soins je pouvais pas aller
chez un médecin parce que j'ai pas la
sécurité sociale parce quelle façon si à
une prescription des examens faire après
faut les payer
moi j'étais toxicomane jeu concia avoir
à me procurer de l'argent pour acheter
la drogue tout ça sans me faire attraper
se loger se nourrir un problème
quotidien pour marie à cette époque sida
et exclusion l'association aides de mme
lr aujourd'hui la maladie recule sur
l'ensemble de la france
mais progresse dans certains quartiers
un malade du sida sur quatre habite en
banlieue parisienne en ile de france est
la région la plus touchée de l'europe il
est plus qu'à déciderait plus de
personnes vivant avec le vih en ile de
france que dans les pays ancré comme
l'angleterre ou l'allemagne
la situation socio économique des
quartiers difficiles en ile-de-france
surtout offre un terrain favorable à la
maladie une population plus jeune un
taux de chômage élevé et surtout
l'inégalité dans l'accès aux soins
46 % des séropositifs ne se savait pas
malade faute de sus du médical peut-être
que l'éducation sanitaire n'est pas
suffisante pour bien faire comprendre
que dépister tôt la maladie a plus de
chances d'être stoppé dans son évolution
et c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui fait
problème
les associations militent surtout pour
un meilleur accès aux soins car la
présence médicale en banlieue reste
inférieur à la moyenne nationale
nous vous le rappelions vendredi soir
les allocations familiales sont
désormais placés sous conditions de
ressources cette mesure prend effet au
1er mars et concernera les prestations
versées à partir du mois d'avril les
explications nécessaires
olivier caroff
désormais il ne suffira plus d'avoir des
enfants pour toucher les allocations
familiales à partir du mois d'avril
elles ne seront versés qu'en dessous
d'un plafond de revenu imposable
si vous gagnez plus de 25000 francs nets
par mois avait deux enfants
vous pouvez dire adieu à vos allocs
glissé un petit nouveau arrive dans la
famille le plafond remonte de 5000
francs le gouvernement a par ailleurs
prévu des cas particuliers le plafond
passe à 32 mille francs nets par mois
toujours avec deux enfants
si le couple travail ou si la famille
est monoparentale
cette mise sous condition de ressources
devrait privés d'allocations familiales
plus de 350 mille foyers
une mesure transitoire en attendant le
grand débat sur la famille prévue pour
cet été et pour toute information
complémentaire vous pouvez contacter la
caisse nationale d'allocations
familiales au numéro 08 36 67 50 00 qui
s'affiche sur votre écran en corse
campagne électorale pour les prochaines
territoriales après l'assassinât du
préfet de région il ya trois semaines
les candidats bac la campagne sous
protection rapprochée comme l'a constaté
benoît duquesne en suivant emile
zuccarelli qui pour la première fois est
à la tête d'une liste unie de la gauche
ce qui est exceptionnel pour un candidat
dans cette campagne ce n'est pas tant de
faire des kilomètres d'écumé la corse
c'est de le faire sous haute
surveillance avec voiture suiveuse et
protection rapprochée alors on concilie
les circonstances exceptionnelles et la
tradition et quand on s'appelle emile
zuccarelli ministre en exercice la
tradition c'est de rendre visite au
maire de chaque ville traversée
même s'il n'est pas tout à fait de votre
bord et hachez le ministre
chers amis c'est un à l'air bonhoure que
de recevoir à la mairie de quartier et
dans son hommage le maire n'oublie pas
que pour la première fois la gauche se
présente unie assez territoriale emile
zuccarelli a sur sa liste deux atouts de
poids dominique bucchini le maire
communiste de sartène et françois
giacobbi est riche et son père et de la
famille radicale et qui espère bien
reprendre la haute corse à la droite
alors on fait campagne même si les
hommes du gipn sont là et même s'il faut
indiquer pour plus de sécurité
chacun de ses déplacements au jardin
en fait ça les jaunards je fais ça avec
les arabes qui c'est une nécessité dans
la mesure où est la mesure où il ya des
gendarmes qui qui me sont proches
spécialement protégée vous avez tous nos
vies et pourquoi vous avez eu des
menaces particulières à j'ai cru
comprendre que dans la situation de la
corse
il y avait un certain nombre d'élus
haute autorité qui bénéficieront en
bande d'une certaine attention et en
meeting on parle aussi de cela de
sécurité de dérives mafieuses de sursaut
citoyen sans que les corses et leur est
dû soit forcément sur la même longueur
d'onde tirés dont le coeur a battu à
l'occasion des récents événements je
crois qu'il faut vous avez mis en cause
la population corse je regrette je ne
suis pas et je ne me sens pas ni
responsables ni coupables encore jeu et
hi fi mais il ya des comportements qui
s'est un moment donné il faut bien que
nous ce serait si je n'y a pas de
société
et quant à rumeurs encore se veut que
les tueurs du préfet erignac est déjà
possible d'autres hommes politiques
chacun c'est ici que la composition de
la future assemblée n'est pas
les élections régionales dans la région
provence alpes côte d'azur devrait se
jouer au coude à coude de la majorité
plurielle doit désormais compter avec
lucien weygand qui fait cavalier seul
exclu du parti socialiste il ya quelques
jours ils risquent de jouer les arbitres
lors du prochain scrutin
guilaine chenu franz vaillant
elle n'est pas encore une figure de la
canebière pourtant c'est bien lui michel
vauzelle le candidat de la gauche
plurielle aux régionales
une seule affiche pour les communistes
les radicaux le mouvement des citoyens
et quelques verres c'est une première
une union presque parfaite s'il n'y
avait le sien weygand tel parti
socialiste
l'ucv gandhi lui 64 ans et 48 ans de
militantisme est exclue depuis quelques
jours du parti socialiste
il fait une liste tout seul et menaces
d'arracher à la gauche les quelques
sièges nécessaires pour gagner ses
anciens amis sont devenus ses ennemis d
entre vous et monsieur vauzelle
il s'agit bien d'une querelle de pouvoir
président du conseil général lucien des
gants règne sur ce paquebot de 2000
fonctionnaires et 6 milliards de budget
un fauteuil très convoité qu'il aurait
accepté de quitter en échange d'un an
mais voilà françois bernardini le patron
de la puissante fédération des bouches
du rhône ne l'entend pas ainsi
il a infligé par une légitimité qui
considérait très personnelle d'avoir un
poste sur les sénatoriales et on en est
là pour cette seule et unique raison et
au milieu de cette guerre déclenchée
pour un fauteuil de sénateur michel
vauzelle aujourd'hui
je crois que il est une chance
historique pour la gauche pour les
républicains de faire barrage au front
national michel vauzelle tente de
recentrer le débat sur l'enjeu et les
idées une campagne de rassemblement
rattrapé par les divisions en angleterre
manifestation des campagnes qui sont
venus par dizaines de milliers
défilaient dans les rues du centre de
londres à l'origine de cette marée verte
la défense de la chasse à courre
auxquels se sont joints les éleveurs
frappés par la crise de la vache folle
et les fermiers des intérêts divergents
avec une seule revendication collective
laissez nous vivre etienne leenhardt
dieu que les campagnes anglaises sont
élégantes lorsqu elle s'apprête à
marcher sur l'eau à ces politiciens de
la ville qui entendent leur interdire
chasse à courre armes à feu et le droit
de vivre sur leurs terres comme ils
l'entendent
250000 manteau kaki et chapeau de tweed
sont donc venus dire poliment leur façon
de penser
seule la délégation française ajoutant
une larme de franc parler dans cet océan
de 17
moi non
les gens qui habitent la campagne
c'est pour eux une tradition que les
gens débit ne peut pas comprendre
il n'en reste pas moins que le débat sur
la chasse en grande bretagne et chauffe
en permanence les esprits aujourd'hui
encore pro et anti se sont dits sans se
cacher leurs quatre vérités
l'opposition conservatrice s'était
largement associée aux défilés hauts
risques pour les organisateurs de voir
cette défense de la ruralité transformer
en un acte politique contre le
gouvernement travailliste
ce projet ce n'est pas vraiment
politique il ya des gens de tous les
partis qui viennent de tout le pays
et ça paie plus les gens qui ont
manifesté aujourd'hui souhaitent
conserver leur mode de vie et
précisément nous voulons laisser la
politique en dehors de tout ça face à
cette démonstration de force le
gouvernement travailliste de tony blair
oppose une relative indifférence car en
la matière tout est affaire de
proportion est officiellement trois
britanniques sur quatre sont opposés à
la chasse à courre pour passer le cap du
21e c'est que l'agriculture fait l'objet
de toutes les attentions et cet ensemble
qu'universitaire chercheurs et
agriculteurs prépare le futur l'enjeu
est considérable et les possibilités
infinies de marier les produits du
terroir et de jouer sur les goûts de
demain l'exemple d'une collaboration
unique
olivier galzi dans les entrailles de
l'auvergne les caves des fromages et
n'ont pas résisté à la modernité tout
abandonné pour des chambres froides
aseptisé tout ou presque car il existe
des résistants dans la famille guillaume
on est à finir de père en fils ici les
saint nectaire dorment toujours dans les
profondeurs de la montagne là où le
temps s'est arrêté
c'est un acteur puisque la plus
traditionnelle 1 absolument
ils sont affinés comme il ya une
cinquantaine d'années dans des caves
naturelles qui ont été creusées dans le
pub volcaniques
on n'a pas modifié fait qu absolument
pas changement de décor à quelques
kilomètres de là le fromage a quitté la
fraîcheur tranquille décale pour les
éprouvettes
nous sommes à l'inra près de clermont
ferrand
c'est l'autre face de l'agriculture
auvergnate quand la recherche se met au
service du terroir cette machine est une
sorte de super n'est bien plus puissante
qu'un et humain elle va pouvoir
identifier l'origine de chacun des arums
dégagée par le fromage ce type
d'instrumentation permet d'extraire les
substances volatiles des aliments afin
de pouvoir les identifier ce qui permet
de
mieux gérer la qualité et d'améliorer la
qualité des produits qu'ils consomment
le but de cette agriculture en blouse
blanche combinée les produits du terroir
avec les normes européennes
en clair marié la sécurité alimentaire
avec l'amour du goût mais l'avenir de
notre agriculture est peut-être en
partie dans cette serre à l'ambiance
étrange ces plantes sont toutes des
mutante génétiquement transformé elles
sont le fleuron de l'agriculture
auvergnate à la pointe de la recherche
dans ce domaine nous sommes chez
limagrain géant mondial de la semence
dans son coffre fort pas de billets de
banque non mais des plantes
transgéniques jalousement gardée des
plantes dont le but ultime est de
produire des protéines thérapeutiques
c'est à dire non plus des aliments mais
des médicaments vous avez ici par
exemple un plan de tabac dans lequel on
a introduit le gène de l'hémoglobine
humaine cette plante va donc produire
l'hémoglobine humaine qui sera destiné à
devenir un nouveau médicament
on peut encore parler d'agriculture et
ce niveau là c'est l'agriculture de
demain
l'agriculteur devient un mollet culteurs
son chant devient une usine à molécules
c'est la première étape de la production
d'un nouveau médicament
paradoxalement l'agriculture saute dans
le 21e siècle sans véritablement changé
de visage mais tout de même
le cultivateur auvergne et en producteur
de molécules voilà qui devrait
d'enterrer bien des clichés
le chancelier helmut kohl à chartres ce
matin pour célébrer le cinquantenaire de
la mort de l'abbé franz stock ce prêtre
allemand surnommé l'aumônier de l'enfer
qui fut aumônier des prisons parisiennes
pendant l'occupation puis s'occupe à des
séminaristes allemands retenus en france
après la libération le cardinal lustiger
a célébré une messe solennelle dans la
cathédrale de chartres en présence du
chancelier de rené monory présidente du
sénat
en allemagne élections testant basse
saxe qui devrait désigner le challenger
d'helmut kohl lors des prochaines
élections législatives de septembre
prochain selon les premières estimations
la star de l'opposition gerhard schröder
l'un des hommes les plus populaires
d'allemagne remporte haut la main
l'élection du land c'est donc lui qui
affrontera helmut kohl candidats pour un
cinquième mandat
olivier lerner le prochain champ celui
allemand ce sera peut être lui
gerhard schröder social démocrate
centriste
il a mis en jeu toute sa carrière
politique aujourd'hui son pari écrasez
christian wulff jeune candidat chrétien
démocrate
un des poulains d'helmut kohl qui avait
la lourde tâche de contrer schrijder
pour qu'ils n'obtiennent pas plus de 42
3% des voix un chiffre clé dans cette
élection régionale transformé en enjeu
national ou helmut kohl a fait campagne
pour nous comme il l'aurait fait pour
lui un scrutin en trois dimensions pour
guerra shrugged d'abord conserver son
fauteuil de ministre président de basse
saxe
mais surtout passer la barre des 40 2,3
pour cent pour se placer en position de
force face à cole pour les élections
générales du 27 septembre prochain
et du même coup écarter son rival de
toujours le président du spd oskar
lafontaine l'homme d'appareil plus
vraiment populaire
gerhard schröder que l'on surnomme ici
le tony blair allemand a donc gagné son
pari avec brio et les choses n'ont pas
traîné ce soir puisque le spd l'a
désigné officiellement pour briguer la
chancellerie il est vrai que tous les
sondages donnent ce revers gagnant
contre cole indétrônable chancelier
depuis 16 ans en serbie grave incident
dans la province du kosovo peuplé à
majorité de populations d'origine
albanaise incident entre la police et
les opposants au régime de belgrade
les affrontements auraient provoqué la
mort de 20 personnes dont quatre
policiers selon en radio belgrade
et puis cette prouesse de la technologie
militaire un avion espion américain
capable de voler sans pilote comme on le
voit sur ces images a été présentée pour
la première
aujourd'hui sur la base d'edwards en
californie il est capable de surveiller
une région grande comme la moitié de la
france en 24 heures et il a une
autonomie de vol de près de deux jours
retour en france sport le club amateur
de bourg peronnas réalisé un véritable
exploit hier soir en huitièmes de finale
de la coupe de france en éliminant metz
les supporteurs du petit club de l'ain
rêve maintenant à d'autres exploits
l'ambiance à bourg peronnas sébastien
ayrault et jean-paul nioto bourg
peronnas cet après midi la petite ville
a retrouvé sa tranquillité au bar des
supporters
on a cependant bien du mal à retourner
sur terre après la fête d'hier soient ou
non en cours dans la fête puisque la
victoire a été au rendez-vous et puis la
fatigue on oublie un de machine à
timbrer falloir aller au boulot belle
ambiance elle est un peu retombé parce
que beaucoup d'entre eux me sens fatigué
mais je pense que le bonheur est
toujours présent les grands absents de
la journée ce sont les joueurs du club
de bourg peronnas fatigués épuisés ils
sont restés chez eux
mais il reste au centre de toutes les
discussions mal payés et lieberman 22h15
hier soir au stade gerland l'heure de la
délivrance fini la souffrance les
joueurs du bourg peronnas viennent
d'éliminer messe de la coupe de france
des amateurs donne une leçon de football
à des professionnels acteurs 1 avec ce
tir de david duratti c'est le premier
but de la partie
acte 2 quarante minutes plus tard c'est
la désillusion des messins la
consécration de didier collet les jeux
sont faits metz est battu 2 0 à ses
immenses
je sais puisque enfin c'est fabuleux
tous ceux ville derrière mots on osait à
peine l'espère été fait et en plus je
pense sur le match
bon on ne mérite méritait aussi
l'accueil des supporters il est 23h30
les héros fatigués sont de retour à
bourg péronnas vingt mille personnes
mais attendre quatre heures du matin la
fête est désormais terminée pour les
joueurs partis se coucher
un repos bien mérités de leur côté les
supporters en profite et rêve déjà d'un
nouvel exploit en quarts de finale et
puis en athlétisme patricia girard a
décroché une médaille d'or au 60 m haies
lors des championnats d'europe de
valence en espagne
alexandre kara une marseillaise pour une
parisienne qui a bien du mal à cacher
son émotion
patricia girard un petit bout de
championne une fille en or lors celui du
60 m haies la médaille celle des
championnats d'europe d'athlétisme en
salle de valence
patricia championne d'europe une
nouvelle fois en 96 déjà elle s'était
emparée du plus beau métal à stockholm
mais entre temps il ya eu le doute entre
temps il y a eu à ten les championnats
du monde et patricia girard disqualifié
pour de faux départ il faut dire que
c'est son point fort un temps de
réaction particulièrement rapide qui lui
permet de prendre le meilleur sur ses
adversaires
à presque 30 ans patricia girard réussi
une formidable fin de carrière
ce nouveau titre européen vient
s'ajouter à celui de 96 mais aussi à sa
médaille de bronze olympique décrochée
sur 100 m haies à atlanta
ok en tennis la défaite de cédric
pioline qui s'est incliné cet après-midi
en deux sets 7 5 6 4 face au russe
evgeny kafelnikov en finale du tournoi
de londres kafelnikov remporté le 15e
titre de sa carrière et passe de la 7e à
la 5e place au classement atp
a bordeaux des championnats plutôt
inédit puisque en piscine les meilleurs
photographes sous marins se sont
affrontés ce week end en apnée ou avec
des bouteilles la prise de vue et est
libre selon l'imagination de chacun
françois privat frédéric grain chèque
on a beaucoup dit merci on voulait
passer difficilement c'est pas évident
donc il faut qu'on ait de la patience ou
arriver à avoir un instant où on va
pouvoir déclencher jean-marc de bâti est
un véritable champion de la photo
subaquatique l'hiver en piscine l'été au
fond des mers
depuis 15 ans il est en recherche
perpétuelle du pichet inédits des mains
posées ou liberté totale et 90 minutes
d'épreuve pour les équipes de ces
championnats de france de photos
subaquatique le matériel performant et
très sonné plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de francs
mais seul compte la réussite de la prise
d'eau bénite les tables lumineuses
discussions et décisions toujours
difficile à prendre
chaque équipe choisit trois photos c'est
toujours un peu surprenant et bien même
pour nous entre les accessoires et la
mise en scène qu'on réalise sous l'eau
et puis le résultat sur l'image c'est
vrai qu'il ya toujours une part
d'inconnu où on est émerveillé ou déçu
un petit peu du travail le jury a
tranché
voici le meilleur cliché de ces
championnats avant de plonger encore au
fond de la piscine cérémonie des césars
hier au théâtre des champs elysées un
triomphe pour le film d'alain resnais on
connaît la chanson enfin césar pour luc
besson meilleur réalisateur est une
surprise plein d'émotion pour la
jeunesse de marius couronnée meilleure
actrice de l'année nous la recevons dans
un instant mais avant parole d'acteurs
et remise des trophées auxquels
assistaient parce qu'elle deschamps fait
des films qui brûlent fait des films qui
glace est pas des films tiède fait des
films qui émerveille fait des chine qui
éveille tous deux avaient décidé de
réenchanter le monde
ariane ascaride et robert guédiguian
leur marius et jeannette deux anonymes
au grand coeur nous ont donné
ils ne sont des tolérances tu veux juste
dire à mon père qu'il a certainement
gagné ses ailes d'ange garder pour
l'éternité
mais si vous comme seul lui avait décidé
de faire chanter la vie d'un jeune
réalisateur de 75 ans surgit là où on ne
l'attendait pas avec on connaît la
chanson il a donné le tempo à deux
millions de spectateurs et rappelé ses
césars dont celui du meilleur acteur
pour andré dussollier vont m'encourager
à vous chanter une chanson et ce sera d
âge celui du meilleur scénario et des
meilleur second rôle pour des habitués
agnès jaoui et jean pierre bacri les
temps que le secret soit totalement levé
sur ce projet et puisque le cinéma ne se
fait pas hors du monde il y a eu l'appel
à la vigilance des opposants à la amy
l'accord multilatéral sur
l'investissement
la mine est donc pas un ami lamy est
notre ennemi ou encore l'hommage de jean
luc godard ou cinéastes qui l'an dernier
ont soutenu les sans papiers le cinéma
pour la première fois est apparu à la
non par la dernière passe mais à la
première page du journal
il n'est pas par l'une des décorations
ou avec la grosse caisse du tiroir
caisse comme faisant des recettes
magnifique il est apparu jeux sont là
des scellés cinéaste il ya de l'honneur
là dedans ça me permet d'avoir envie de
continuer et donc je les remercie les
électrices ma famille avec juliette
binoche une famille qui certes ne
parlent pas toujours la même langue mais
au même langage et ce n'est pas le
moindre des mérites des césars que d'en
avoir réuni une fois de plus même si
chacun reprend aujourd'hui des chemins
différents qui les enfants
du plaisir maintenant de recevoir
aryenne nascar et devant soir corinne
est donc meilleure actrice de l'année
vous étiez sans doute le moment
d'émotion de de cette soirée est une
émotion difficile à contenir à ce
qu'aujourd'hui encore elle est palpable
cette émotion mais c'est pas encore
complètement ça mais j'espère que demain
matin ça ira
alors vous avez dédié césar alors je
vais citer votre phrase à toutes les
femmes combatives dîner et anonymes qui
font changer et avancer le monde
elle vous ressemblent ces femmes là tout
cas j'espère que je leur ressemble je
dirais plutôt ça comme ça et j'espère
que je vais continuer alors ressemblé à
être le plus proche d'elle le plus
possible je crois que c'est ces femmes
là qui font fait que les choses avancent
ces femmes qui tous les jours se lève
les premières se couche les dernières
ces femmes qui apprennent le respect des
autres à leurs enfants ces femmes qui
sans bruit faut beaucoup beaucoup de
travail
c'était le cas de votre femme nue oui
mais mr quelqu'un comme ça j'ai été
élevé par des femmes comme ça et si je
n'avais pas été par des femmes comme ça
je serais certainement pas là ce soir
alors à votre avis que doit-on retenir
de ce film mary c'est jeannette dans le
succès dépasse toutes les espérances
j'ai envie de dire qu'il ya une morale
et que c'est une belle morale optimiste
réenchanter la vie dit le metteur en
scène je crois que ce qu'il faut se dire
c'est qu'il n'ya pas de fatalité que les
choses ne nous arrive pas dessus comme
ça qu'on ne peut rien faire contre
contraire je crois qu'il faut
recommencer à se parler et à s'écouter
et je crois qu on est toujours plus fort
ensemble que tout seul alors le grand
public ne connaît pas forcément votre
visage qu'à peut-être pas tout
l'ensemble de votre carrière
gérez vous êtes une comédienne vous avez
fait le conservatoire vous êtes
également une militante comme ça qu'on
peut vous devenu oui il est temps de
veut dire être citoyenne prendre parti à
l'existence de la cité dans laquelle je
vis mais je crois que tout le monde est
comme ça je suis pas quelqu'un qui
laisse les choses passées sur moi sans
que je réagisse je crois que c'est
important tout le monde a droit à une
parole je prends mon droit ses troupes
alors ce césar vous donne le sentiment
d' asseoir confortablement votre
carrière ou vous savez le plus tôt le
vertige vous tanguay
oui je tends encore un peu mais je crois
que je vais arriver à remettre mes deux
pieds sur terre comme il faut et surtout
je vais continuer mon travail
tranquillement
alors je voudrais quand même souligner
que ses fils marius et jeannette est un
film que l'on appelle à petit budget et
que vous n'avez pas dans votre carrière
ni dans ce film eu l'habitude des
tournages facile oui c'est les tournages
hollywoodiens
non les tournages je vais vous dire je
ne sais pas trop ce que ses cheveux j'ai
toujours travaillé en tout cas avec
robert guédiguian n'a souvent à
travailler dans des conditions assez
minimales mais jean par exemple ça fait
pas très longtemps qu'on dort à l'hôtel
quand on fait des tournages avec robert
on a dormi dans des foyers de
travailleurs on a dormi chez des gens
qui nous prêtaient leur appartement
mais par contre qu'on a une richesse
bien plus grande je crois que tous les
studios d'hollywood c'est une immense
solidarité une immense amitié qui nous
lie et qui fait qu'on fait ces films là
on sent que c'est pas simplement du
travail c'est des moments de vie je
crois que ce sens et se sent également
dans dans cette interview peut-être
encore un mot qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter ce soir rien de continuer ce
que je suis il va faite le merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
tout de même à mots sur l'ubs baissant à
luc besson est souvent maltraité par la
critique est depuis toujours privé de
récompenses luc besson à qui l'on doit
le cinquième élément mais c'est une
équipe tard le grand bleu leone a reçu
hier son premier oscar celui du meilleur
réalisateur qu'il commente avec pascal
deschamps et bruno livertout quand on
reçoit plus tôt c'est un encouragement
mais c'est vrai que ça m'aurait fait
plaisir plus jeunes d'avoir cet
encouragement la deux de mes pairs dire
c'est bien mon petit gars vas-y continue
comprendre comme ça et ça c'est vrai que
c'est bien quand on la passe est vrai
que ça frustre pas ce qu'on dit mais
pourquoi ils me reconnaissent pas
pourquoi ils m'aiment pas donc c'est
vrai que il ya le plaisir du un peu tard
ce qui est très paradoxal c'est que par
l'emploi public lui n'a pas attendu
quinze ans qu'on le trouve un peu de
talent
c'est généralement les journalistes
oublient ce qu'oublie qu'on peut aimer
godard et les sandales maintien bat
simplement pas les voir même jour mais
il ya une partie du public qui le même
on va aller voir on va les voir le livre
de la jungle avec les enfants et puis
après on va devoir woody allen s'est par
exemple vraiment ravi de 2,2 de
rencontrer monsieur rené parce qu'il a
quand même fait des films formidables et
oui c'était c'était mignon quoi pascal
garbe ouais mais vous aussi vous avez
parlé on s'était quand même incroyable
magie des hommes et providence et s
était fou quoi bon c'est vrai qu'il dit
est incroyable et moi je dis d'enfer
mais les amateurs de disques aux anciens
auront trouvé sans doute leur bonheur ou
salon qui se tient actuellement à paris
des trésors phonographique et des
chansons gravées sur vinyle et le disco
qui fait déjà partie des objets de
collection nicolas winckler crm linge et
20 mille francs pour ce disque rare de
johnny non seulement ça ne nous rajeunit
pas mais en plus ce risque fort de nous
ruiner ce qui fait le prix d'un disque
c'est naturellement sa rareté
très prisé les disques des stars édités
avant qu'elles ne soient célèbres comme
ce léo qui n'avait pas encore été ferrés
par une maison de disques now shurmur
perche et c'est laurent voulzy un groupe
inconnu qui chante les plaisirs
solitaires mais y'a pas de mal parce
qu'elle se vend à l'époque où il se
prenait pour pascal sevran et cet
étonnant bernard tapie y croit quand
même bernard tapie y en avait trois et
musicalement c'était assez sympa
l'ombre énoncé pour le seul effet il est
sorti là une vinyle une galette en
plastique des souvenirs en inde c'est ma
belle soeur qui est en israël qui
cherchent à presque tout cas ça fait six
ans que je le cherche
amour
est ce que j'avais peur d'acheter un
disque rayé pour simplement vérifier
l'état mais en général nous sont en bon
état
est-ce que moi j'avais peur d'acheter un
disque rayé il faut vérifier l'état en
généralement ils sont bons
est-ce qu'on n'a jamais peur d'acheter
un disque rayé ça arrive quelques fois
cette année un hommage la disco
française des millions d'exemplaires
vendus à travers le monde
on y apprend une chose étonnante
ouailles m6 et a été écrit par un
français les villes est super lourds
dégâts szczesny et j'arrive à dispo
s'est exportée en français mais aussi en
amérique 1 210 chevaux vous chantez en
amérique un faux sac on ne s'est pas
noyé m6 est une chanson française
les 10 h people quelque part un peu
français n'est ce pas que la joie inonde
vos coeurs faites quoi du vinyle au
latex il n'y a qu'un pas
courage fuyons ainsi se termine cette
édition je vous en rappelle les
principaux titres c'est l'ouverture
inauguration par jacques chirac ce matin
il salon de l'agriculture un événement
une attraction pour le bonheur des plus
petits qui découvrent tous les animaux
de la ferme
le décès du cardinal archevêque de lyon
monseigneur balance était un ce matin à
une semaine après avoir été nommé
cardinal par le pape jean paul ii dans
un instant la météo isabelle martinez
20h55 présumé innocent votre film avec
harrison ford de master 50 dans les 4
vérités
françoise laborde recevra louis le
pensec ministre de l'agriculture et de
la pêche en direct du salon de
l'agriculture pour retrouverez demain
soir daniel bilalian je vous remercie de
votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2